follow my finger with your eyes in your
eyes only don't flick me off in this
company in flashbacks remember sometimes
tequila sometimes it's fine a little
whiskey a little bhakta
look at this face every look
intimidating yeah I got you did you
learn that unlike while you were coffee
you are talking way too much was drunk
I'm Jim Huertas former law enforcement
12 years today I'm gonna try and figure
out who's drunk I'm down here for sure
you do drink I do yeah that's okay yeah
I do too
when I'm off work makes sense yeah what
you drink a choice a little whiskey a
little bhakta that's what the mixed No
oh yeah depends on what day of the week
it is whether you mix em or not Monday
you mix Friday makes the rest of time
you don't make sense so how'd you get to
work today I drove yeah and you're
driving home I am you sure I am how far
away do you live about 17 miles Oh kind
of office that's quite the trek yeah all
right thank you for your cooperation
Blake how about you making me nervous I
mean it no more than any other
interrogation this is an interview not
an intern and you like an interrogation
that's I mean I don't know the
difference
two out one is me being nice cop in the
others maybe a bad cop there you know it
might be good for the video
yeah well it's really not my nature I'm
kind of a I'm officer friendly most of
the time okay so unless I need to not be
do I need to not be I'm gonna think you
got a pretty good crowd over here I
think everybody's cool look at this face
everyone it's intimidating yeah I got
you did you learn that and look like
while you're a cop
you are talking way too much you realize
that right I've never been to negated by
a cop before I have enabled you you're
talking more than I am how am I supposed
to interrogate or even interview if
you're talking more than I ask you
Europe no I'm done thanks man scar come
on down here for me please you've done
this before
none skating practice okay you ready
done for next time up why do they call
you scar will you see my face right well
because of the scar in your face
yeah okay what's drunk it's not 5:00 yet
so it's not me what's your drink of
choice well I was drinking some vitamin
water right now you know you know what
don't make some good pruno by the way no
you do it yeah where'd you learn that
Alison you use potatoes I was in the Boy
Scouts okay you get your Bruno veg then
use potatoes but he's gotta have a
kicker yeah guys speed up the process
yeah sugar should get lots of lots of
sugar okay
Jubilee I always blank it's how I keep
my eyes moist all right come on down oh
yes well save the best for last right
what's your drink of choice when you
partake sometimes tequila
sometimes it's wine kind of depends on
the night mm okay what kind of night was
it today
today it's so night yet so you only
drink at night Teddy do me a favor stand
right over there for me okay and face me
put your feet together heels and toes
and Zen at your side okay you see my
finger I want you to focus on my finger
right here okay I want you to follow
with your eyes and your eyes only don't
move your head okay
okay give me a favor reach out and touch
the tip of my finger perfect that's
where I want you to watch there's three
acceptable tests in law enforcement for
deciding if or at least administering
these tests to determine if somebody's
impaired or not it's the one leg stand
the walk and turn and nystagmus test try
not to wet smile you can smile the best
part about this is you're not getting
arrested okay so you can smile you can
smile you want can you say you're awful
bet back now I'm just kidding
go ahead Teddy stand right over there
it's Spencer same thing for you please
heels and toes together we're not doing
the whole field sobriety test we're not
I'm just just looking at your eyes by
looking at a person's eyes and having
them follow my finger the more you drink
of the higher your BAC the more
pronounced that nystagmus is and I
segments is the involuntary jerking of
your eyes
the motion so when when following my
finger when I take the eye all the way
out to the edge on both sides that's
when you can see it oh you're done I
stepped away I didn't ask you to look at
you thinking you're controlling things
they're all like yeah how'd you get to
work today are you getting home
sure you need what would say sir like
Blake yep and again you've done this no
I'm just kidding
yeah you have a cop friend who's done it
in a bar right no it was a real cop
doing it to me but it was like I think
you just decided pretty quick there
wasn't oh that's good yeah there's like
the first thing yeah I already know
whether these two are not so it's just
no it's just a process of elimination
right you get still and I'm not even
doing this the full way so can you do me
a favor God won't you put your feet
together like that
hands down each side okay don't start
yet okay not until I tell you to okay
when I ask you to I'm gonna have you
lift your foot whichever one you want
okay about six inches off the ground
about the height of a coke can
right point your toe stare at your toe
and count one one thousand two one
thousand three one thousand four one
thousand five and so on it's a time to
maneuver I'll tell you I'll tell you
when to stop okay okay it's not it's not
a it's it's not a pass/fail thing that's
just an observation
okay you understand till I tell you Soph
you ready you may begin
that's good back out there Skaar step on
it does hey Ben today yeah me too
are you sure you haven't started already
oh you're not sure I can't afford
perfect all right do me a favor follow
my finger with your eyes in your eyes
only okay don't flick me off in this I
won't that won't do that
all right do me a favor take take about
two steps back
yeah right there all right I want you to
take your left leg okay put it in front
of your right foot just like that which
put your hands down at your side okay
when I tell you to begin I'm going to
have you take eight steps heel to toe
make sure your heel touches your toe hey
keeping your hands down at your side
you're gonna count your steps out loud
one two three all the way up to eight
okay
and then you're gonna turn around I'm
not a good dancer that's okay that's
alright pretty simple just make sure you
know here your feet are only this big
alright you may begin
[Music]
and even the pirouette at the end
perfect so thank you very much perfect
all right I think I've seen enough and
I'm gonna go ahead and say that Spencer
has been drinking today in the
drunk-person step forward
hi hi why are you giggling because now
you can be relaxing nah yeah because
I've been drinking at my desk for like
the last 30 minutes all like that no no
and what did you drink was it no it was
mine oh I know a really hard thing to
chug yeah yeah how much you think you
had your eyes are showing it I'm sure
your eyes are showing it for sure I did
a dry January so this is the first time
I've drank in a month still have 31st I
know well I made an exception today
today's a celebration and wine was a
good choice cause Akins couldn't smell
any alcohol so great I also had a mint
and a beverage
since the wine I'll get over vary the
masking puss
we tried yeah well you didn't you did
well that way the the eyes are
definitely the windows to the soul so
they gave you away
well thanks for your participation hey
thanks so obviously it's a it's a little
easier to tell if somebody's been
drinking as opposed to getting high and
again the eyes tell everything the eyes
are the windows to the soul glad I was
able to redeem myself on this one
[Music]